شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
غرفتنا هي مشروع جديد أنشأه
طاقم No Way Out والذي اكتسب
شعبية كبيرة بين السائحين المحليين
منذ اليوم الأول حيث تم
افتتاحه بتفاصيل رائعة
وانغماس كامل في الممثلين المباشرين، ولن تعرف
ما الذي ستفعله  'لا تكون مفقودًا إلا عندما تأتي
وتشعر بذلك بنفسك،
يتوفر للضيوف ثلاث غرف أفلام للاختيار
من بينها، غرفة سينما واحدة، غرفة معيشة كلاسيكية
لمجموعة كبيرة من الأشخاص الذين يتنقلون،
غرفة 2 مع سرير يتسع لشخصين إلى أربعة أشخاص
وأخرى جديدة تمامًا  سيتم افتتاحه
قريبًا جدًا، وقد تم تصميم كل غرفة مع التركيز
على الانغماس في التكنولوجيا والجودة العالية،
لدينا تصميمات مخصصة من قبل فريقنا
لنمنحك بالفعل واحدة من أفضل الأفلام في
صناعة الأفلام
عندما تشاهدها كما لو
كنت تشاهد الفيلم.  الفيلم وأنا
مع مجتمع المشاهدة هذا،
لدينا مؤثرات واقعية خاصة
تكون في لحظات مكثفة عندما
تشاهد الفيلم، ربما تكون
جالسًا ثم يكون لديك شيء مثل
الاهتزاز الذي يأتي من التأثيرات في
الفيلم القادم  يضيء لك أيضًا أثناء
مشاهدتك للفيلم أو ربما
تمر بلحظة مظلمة حيث ترى
مثل الشبح في الفيلم والشيء التالي
هو أن تجلس المحكمة بجوارك [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية